.
LEE ZELDIN WILL JOIN US, HE HAS
BEEN ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL WITH
RON DeSANTIS.
HERE'S A NEW GREEN GARAGE FIRST.
I LOVE WHEN YOU'RE RIGHT, NEWT.
I HAVE TO IDENTIFY THAT YOU ARE
AHEAD OF THE CURVE.
YOU'VE BEEN SAYING CONFIDENTLY
FOR SOME TIME NOW THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE A WAVE ELECTION.
IF THESE PULSE PAN OUT, AND I'M
URGING PEOPLE NOT TO TRUST THEM,
I'M URGING PEOPLE TO KEEP THAT
SENSE OF URGENCY AND RESOLVE,
BUT IF IT PANS OUT YOU'LL BE
READ AGAIN.
I'LL HAVE TO SAY, NEWT GINGRICH
WAS RED AGAIN.
>> FIRST OF ALL, YOUR KEY POINT
IS, EVERYBODY IS WATCHING HAS TO
GO VOTE.
AND THEY HAVE TO GET THEIR
FRIENDS, THE RELATIVES, EVERYONE
THEY KNOW TO GO FORWARD.
IF THAT HAPPENS, IF WE GET THE
KIND OF A TURNOUT, WERE GOING TO
WIN A HISTORICAL ACTION, MAYBE
THE BIGGEST REPUBLICAN VICTORY
SINCE 1920, OVER HUNDRED YEARS
AGO.
BUT THAT'S CAN HAPPEN ONLY IF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TURN UP AND
VOTE.
ALL THE INDICATORS OF THE LAST
FEW DAYS ARE THAT IN FACT, IF
YOU WOULD GET THE RECENT GALLUP
POLL MATERIAL, PEOPLE ARE
TOTALLY DISGUSTED WITH BIDEN AND
WITH THE DEMOCRATS WHO FEEL
DEEPLY THAT THE COUNTRIES ON THE
WRONG TRACK.
GALLUP SAID THEY HAD THE WORST
DATA FOR AN OFF YEAR ELECTION
SINCE THEY BEGAN TAKING THAT
KIND OF A SURVEY IN TERMS OF THE
INCUMBENT DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
YOUR POINT IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
EVERYBODY HAS TO TURN OUT AND
VOTE.
IF THEY DO, I THINK YOU'RE GONNA
SEE A REMARKABLE REPUDIATION OF
A SET OF POLICIES THAT ARE
FRANKLY A DISASTER.
I COULD NOT HAVE DREAMED, WHEN
YOU AND I TOOK ABOUT THIS TWO
YEARS AGO, I COULD NOT HAVE
DREAMED HOW BAD THEY WOULD BE.
I COULDN'T HAVE DREAMED HOW DUMB
THEY WOULD BE AND HOW RADICAL
AND WEIRD THEY WOULD BE.
ALL THOSE THINGS COME HOME.
NOW, I THINK, IT'S LIKE IN A
CAVE-IN.
THE REASON YOU'RE SEEING PEOPLE
LIKE OBAMA BE SO ANGRY IS THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY FACTS ON
THEIR SIDE.
ALL THEY HAVE LESS LEFT HIS RAW
MOTION READ BECAUSE ON EVERY
SINGLE ISSUE THEY'RE NOT LOSING.
IS THAT SINKS IN OVER THE NEXT
SEVEN DAYS, IT'LL JUST LEAD TO
TSUNAMI OF HISTORIC PROPORTIONS.
IF YOU WANT >> Hannity:
DEMOCRATS WILL RUN ON JANUARY 6
AND THEIR HATRED OF
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT IS FIZZLED OUT.
THEN THEY WOULD RUN ON THE DOBBS
DECISION, THAT SEEMS TO HAVE
BACKFIRED ON THEM.
MOST OF THESE RADICAL CANADA
GETS WE'VE DISCOVERED SUPPORT NO
RESTRICTIONS ON ABORTION AND
WOULD ALLOW TO HAVE AN ABORTION
10 MINUTES BEFORE THEIR DUE TO
DELIVER A BABY.
THAT WOULD BE INFANTICIDE.
THEN THE OLD HISTORICAL
PLAYBOOK, REPUBLICANS ARE
RACIST, SEXIST, HOMOPHOBIC,
XENOPHOBIC, AND BY THE WAY THEY
WANT TO CUT YOUR SOCIAL SECURITY
AND VETERANS BENEFITS AND
MEDICARE, NONE OF IT IS TRUE.
THAT'S HER FINAL MESSAGE.
WILL THAT WORK?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THE OBJECTIVE
REALITY IS THAT PEOPLE GO TO THE
GROCERY STORE.
YOU CAN'T RUN ENOUGH ADS FOR
DEMOCRATS TO CONVINCE PEOPLE
THAT ARE NOT PAYING A LOT MORE
MONEY.
THE GOOD OF THE GAS STATION.
YOU CAN PAY FOR ENOUGH ADS TO
CONVINCE THEM THOUGH NOT PAYING
ALL LOT MORE MONEY.
IN THE NORTHEAST, WE HAVE A
DIESEL FUEL SHORTAGE THAT
RELATES DIRECTLY TO HEATING OIL
SHORTAGE, PEOPLE WILL BE
FURIOUS.
I HAVE SOMEONE WHO WORKS WITH ME
WHO SAYS THAT HIS WIFE'S MAT
EVERY SUNDAY WHEN SHE GOES TO
THE GROCERY STORE.
WHEN SHE GETS HOME THE PRICES
ARE SO HIGH, SHE'S JUST FURIOUS.
I THINK THESE THINGS ARE ABOUT
REAL LIFE.
YOU GO HOME, YOU TURN IN THE
EVENING NEWS, YOU FIND OUT HOW
MANY MUGGINGS, KILLINGS,, YOU
LOOK AT THIS WEEKEND IN CHICAGO.
HOW CAN YOU POSSIBLY BE
COMFORTABLE?
FINALLY, YOU HAVE ALL THESE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, ONE OF WHOM
ATTACKED PAUL PELOSI.
THE NATIONAL MEDIA DIDN'T WANT
TO START WITH THAT HEADLINE BUT
HE WAS AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT WHO
SHOULDN'T OF BEEN HERE, THAT'S
THE TRUTH, HE ATTACKED PELOSI.
>> Hannity: IN A SANCTUARY
CITY.
I WANT PAUL PELOSI TO BE SAFE, I
CONCUR.
BUT I WANT EVERY AMERICAN TO BE
SAFE.
WE'VE GOT MORE CRIME, MORE
MURDER, MORE VIOLENT CRIMES THAN
WE'VE SEEN IN DECADES.
THE FACTS SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
82% OF AFRICAN AMERICANS LIST
CRIME IS THEIR BIGGEST ISSUE, IT
IS BEEN REPORTED.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S A BREAK
FOR REPUBLICANS BECAUSE THEIR
PRO-POLICE AND ANTI-CRIMINAL OR
THEY STICK TO THE DEMOCRATS OUT
OF LOYALTY.
BUT WHEN YOU GET NUMBERS LIKE
THAT, ONE OF THE GREAT
ADVANTAGES THE DR. OZ HAS, IN
PHILADELPHIA, 76% OF THE VOTERS
SAY CRIME IS A BIGGEST ISSUE.
FETTERMAN IS PROBE CRIMINAL,
ANTI-POLICE, WANTED TO RELEASE
MURDERERS.
ALL THESE THINGS ARE COMING
TOGETHER AND FRANKLY IN TERMS OF
THE RACE IS JUST STOMACH RACIST
AND XENOPHOBIC STUFF, HOW DO YOU
ATTACK HERSCHEL WALKER FOR
EXAMPLE?
HE'S NOT SENSITIVE ABOUT RACE
SMART IT'S ABSURD.
AND KEVIN McCARTHY'S DONE A
BRILLIANT JOB IN THE HOUSE SIDE.
THEY HAVE MORE MINORITY AND
WOMEN CANDIDATES AND VETERAN
CANDIDATES NEVER IN HISTORY.
IT'S PRETTY HARD TO DESCRIBE
THIS NEW REPUBLICAN PARTY IS THE
WAY THE DEMOCRATS WOULD LIKE TO
DESCRIBE IT.
THEY'RE BECOMING A NARROW PARTY
OF GRADUATE SCHOOL EDUCATED
GRADUATE RADICALS, IN THE
PROCESS ALIENATING LATINOS,
ASIAN AMERICANS, WORKING-CLASS
WHITES, AND, BY THE WAY, WOMEN.
WOMEN AFTER DOBBS, THERE'S BEEN
A 26% SHIFT FROM DEMOCRAT TO
REPUBLICAN IN THE LAST MONTH.
THAT'S AN ASTONISHING NUMBER.
>> Hannity: LAST QUESTION.
PREDICTIONS, ONE WEEK FROM
TOMORROW WILL BE THE MORNING
AFTER ELECTION NIGHT IN AMERICA.
WHAT WILL BE THE NET RESULT IN
YOUR OPINION?
>> YOU WILL BE HAPPY.
>> Hannity: [LAUGHS]
>> HOW ABOUT THAT?
I PERSONAL GUESS IS BEING
CONSERVATIVE PLUS TWO TO PLUS
SEVEN IN THE SENATE, PLUS 22
TWICE PLUS 50 IN THE HOUSE,
MAYBE A LITTLE M